[Musica]
ciao ragazzi bentornati a una nuova
puntata di cucina buttata oggi faremo
una ricetta kurme il motivo per cui mi
sono vestito in maniera un pochino più
[ __ ] rispetto alle solite finge amante
che indosso erano così confortevoli da
smart working mi sono vestito detto ciò
oggi faremo una ricetta con me una
ricetta anche un po romantica alle dosi
sono per due persone che vogliono subito
dopo andare a chiamare leggera ma allo
stesso tempo con un bel mordente con
quel tocco di afrodisiaco che vi
permetterà di avere un così all'europa
faccio cose
no non ho detto con gorgonzola e una
crema di noci andrà tutto vanta una
grande
io vi chiedo veramente di scrivervi
perchè è quello di cose voi non vi
iscrivete questa ricetta non vi farà
[ __ ] sarete mese non vi iscrivete a
questo canale sarete mi farete questa
ricetta e alla fine non troverete con
anima viva quindi io vi chiedo
gentilmente di prendere il vostro c'è e
sbaglia sul mouse e cliccare iscriviti
mentre per le ragazze fate voi cioè nel
senso non conosco bene anatomia
femminile quindi quindi quindi votate
quello che vi pare ma questa qui alla
puntata sessuale bisogna dirlo per fare
la pasta al cacao avremo bisogno di 180
grammi di farina infinito 21 20 grammi
del presente di kakà il sudore quanto
basta è un pizzico di ritenzione idrica
mentre per fare il condimento avremo
bisogno di 100 grammi di gorgonzola 80
grammi di latte materno rubato
15 grammi della mia nemesi 80 grammi di
frutta secca a forma di cervello 10
grammi di pinoli 35 grammi di olio di
olivia che non è mai stata toccata da
uomo uno spicchio di 15 grammi dvd
cavolo che fanno il bene te non li
mettete le acque dentro io ero
felicissimo tiro finisce come vi ho
incontrato di odio innanzitutto
ringraziamo giallozafferano perché come
sempre quello che noi facciamo è rubare
le ricette agli altri li proporlo e
vedere se effettivamente funzionano non
sempre funzionano quindi a me già l'idea
fa cacare
marco io non voglio nemmeno in serie a
parlarti
io non immagino la vita di solitudine e
tristezza che vive la tua ragazza detto
per prima cosa la farina succede anche
ai migliori
andiamo avanti cacao un pizzichino di
sale e iniziamo intanto incorporare
tutto quanto con una forchetta
inizialmente perché non gliela di
sporcarmi le mani mi va di fare niente
in realtà
esame della prostata ma conserve credo
che ci sia un bug che succede e non mi
si stacca dalla mano ma perché in quanto
è frega un cazzo e lame ginecologica
cari questo odio gianmarco ma è
difficile poi veramente è una corsa a
ostacoli psicologica con te le olimpiadi
della psiche strumento sono deluso dal
colore è stato detto che 20 grammi erano
pochi i no tengo io ci sto perdendo il
senno meglio senza guardi sempre ammesso
netto 20 g 23 comunque non erano 20
grammi ho capito gianmarco aspetto la
cosa tu e misurato 2.0 g non 20 perché
guarda avanti sono 20 e il primo giorno
fatto una capatina di piccione adesso
una pasta nera
sicuramente la lettera di cose e nega un
ritratto di gianmarco cielo ma vedere
bene in camera un attimo cielo per
studiare un po
ragazzi è indubbiamente feci vi
troverete alla fine una roba così in
mano la mettete all'interno di una
pellicola trasparente chiudete bene
tutto quanto e lasciamo riposare adesso
in frigo per un'ora il tempo di farli di
creare tutto quanto il reticolato
inutile ma il momento che la mette
sempre la la cosa crea felice io metto
sempre la capsula quella che non entra
mai mettiamo in noce bollino un
pentolino per cinque minuti più o meno
in modo da poter togliere poi la
pellicina nel frattempo velocemente
mettiamo a mollo la mollica con latte
enrico graziani 79 a questo punto
prendiamo la mollica la tiziano per bene
la buttiamo dentro al mixer in cinque
minuti passati ragazzi prendiamo le noci
e le scoliamo al volo
ma queste erano c già senza la buccia sì
quindi non è servito questo step per la
loro già sgusciate c'è ma al momento è
meglio così infiliamo direttamente
dentro il mixer e le ascoltiamo alla
mollica frullone con la mobilità
aggiungiamo adesso pinoli maggiorana uno
spicchio d'aglio così proprio e il
formaggio grattugiato e quindi torniamo
un attimo ammonticchiare bisogna
iniziare a diluire un po alla volta il
composto aggiungendo olio e il latte
quello che abbiamo scolato prima e qui è
augusto ragazzi dovete lavorarlo
praticamente come se fosse il pesto
seguito il cuore sempre
[Musica]
passiamo alla crema con il gorgonzola
facilissimo versiamo tutto il composto
all'interno di una ciotolina e la
mettiamo da parte perché ci servirà dopo
andiamo quindi a sciogliere il nostro
gorgonzola lo mettiamo in una padella e
poi con un po di latte lo aiutiamo a
sciogliersi in questo modo diventerà
bello cremoso tiro shuli ea crema solare
20 che svampa le canzoni da guardare ore
importante a cui piace se per il momento
ci soffermiamo così ma in realtà
potremmo andare a togliere ancora di più
questi piccoli granuli ma non lo
facciamo adesso perché tanto dovremmo
prima cucinare la pasta estenderla
quindi bella li tiriamo fuori dopo
un'ora il nostro meraviglioso composto
consistenza eccellente leggermente
umidiccio ma come vedete non mi macchia
questo vuol dire che per scudo sembrano
l'avvocato prima sembravano cosa vai
farina anche sopra molto dura come pasta
non voglio dare questo messaggio alle
persone che davanti a una difficoltà uno
dei bar piangere e arrendersi no si
piange ma si continua se quello è il tuo
sogno che nei sogni e fare questa pasta
al cioccolato quando avremo ottenuto
questa roba qui e l'avremo accarezzata
ragazzi io è almeno dieci minuti che sto
ad accarezzarlo in questo modo
benissimo togli i bordini perché
dobbiamo fare i fighetti nostri ragazzi
la rimbocchiamo tipo zig zag è una sopra
l'altro è quel punto tagliamo mazzalai
fatta da fighetto è bello è rosa molto
soddisfacente è molto bella e pasta al
cioccolato non mi piaceva parlare bella
buttiamo dentro la pasta dentro l'acqua
naga la pasta fresca in due secondi si
fa è capito quando è fatta perché in
comincia bene a galla questo credo che
lo sappiate rubano tutti però ripeterlo
non fa male
diamo una girata al gorgonzola e ci
prepariamo anche con le noci che andiamo
a unire sbagliamo e sciogliamo tutto
quanto insieme non le metto tutte perché
se non poi diventa troppo noi c'è poco
gorgonzola sta iniziando a vedere tutta
quanto a galla questo vuol dire che tra
pochissimo sarà pronta che era caccia è
veramente tre minuti massimo la pasta è
fatta aggiungiamo la pasta equa acqua di
cottura raga notevolmente calorico per
ragazzi questo è poi diventata e
materiale da matrimonio altro che da
[ __ ] e andiamo a impiattare la
invitiamo in maniera [ __ ] coppins te
cosa che capita se non si trova piazzate
nel piatto
altra crimina che mettiamo sopra come le
ha severamente una faccia equa la mossa
che rischiate di servirlo e dolori
uscire il meno che di mangiare che già
vengono strappati i vestiti da dosso
spolverata di cacao amaro sopra non
troppo adattando sue figlie le metto un
po di più per le tre camere e tanta
tanta se masaccio io direi a questo
punto che non sto più nella pelle
raga dopo quello fa sta roba tromba di
sicuro ma se non è ancora assaggiavano
lo sai su un piatto d'argento ebola le
gonadi del tuo partner delle due partner
sul piatto d'argento un equilibrio di
sapori un intrigo un piatto che prima
ancora di essere un piatto è un mistero
mai provato prima
pazzesco è un piatto fantastico a un
livello alto c'è poco da fare
ragazze se riuscirete a chiamare grazie
a questa ricetta ovviamente mettete un
like che vedeva questo canale fatto
neanche non dovesse riuscirci perché
faremo altre per certe per permettervi
di chiavari un futuro io come sempre vi
mando un bacio grande mi raccomando se
vi farete questa ricetta alla gara di
sinistra
voglio vedere cosa creata invece vediamo
giorni con un uomo video ciao
[Musica]